Con este siglo y la irrupción
de las nuevas tecnologías, el
oficialismo perdió la capacidad de
controlar el flujo informativo.
Construí mi primera computadora en 1994.
Mi esposo recuerdo que bautizó
a todas aquellas piezas regadas
sobre la mesa, como el Frankestein.
Inmediatamente después de tener
la tecnología vino el deseo
de comunicar, de expresar
y de difundir contenido.
Que cuando abrí mi blog fue como un
proceso de exorcismo.
En mi interior había una gran necesidad
de contar, de narrar
y sobre todo de una manera que yo no
había visto narrado.
Yo había visto Cuba narrada desde
la prensa oficial en términos
muy ideológicos, muy políticos.
Faltaban voces desde la gente.
Por otro lado, había una gran
campaña de satanización oficial contra internet.
El oficialismo cubano
estaba ya anunciando
que había algo perverso
y construido por el imperialismo y por el capitalismo.
En mayo de 2014,
junto a un grupo de colegas,
decidimos fundar un diario digital, el primer diario
que se ha hecho de manera independiente desde
dentro de Cuba.
Creó un podcast.
Es un formato muy simple, muy sencillo,
pero increíblemente
llega a mucha gente.
He tenido testimonios muy lindos,
campesinos cubanos, muy, muy mayores.
En medio del campo que me escuchan
y me dicen que ellos no pueden leer ya,
porque sus ojos no se lo permiten,
porque están ciegos, porque no pueden,
no tienen una laptop, pero me escuchan.
14ymedio es un sitio digital
bloqueado en los servidores cubanos.
Pero ojo, Cuba es el país de los trucos.
Llegan a través de proxys anónimos,
llegan a través de servicios de VPN,
llegan a través de copias offline de nuestro sitio.
Este dispositivo tan pequeño
que nos ha cambiado tanto la vida
a los cubanos que es la memoria flash o memoria USB.
Una pequeña memoria flash cabe en
cualquier lugar y puede transportar mucha información.
Entonces la Plaza de la Revolución, el oficialismo cubano
no puede colocar
un policía en cada esquina a ver
quién tiene una memoria flash
y quién no.
Absolutamente me protegen las personas que
me siguen en Twitter.
Es una dinámica que es un poco
difícil de comprender cuando se vive
en el mundo libre y las redes
sociales parecen más un lugar para
el debate, la polémica y la confrontación.
Pero cuando se vive en una sociedad
bajo un régimen totalitario, en una
sociedad vigilada, en una sociedad
controlado hasta cada
segundo de tu vida, las redes sociales se convierten en una
visibilidad protectora.
En noviembre del año 2009
y es que iba a participar
públicamente en una convocatoria
que habían hecho jóvenes artistas
contra la censura, que antes de salir
una amiga me dijo vamos a escribir
un SMS, un mensaje de texto,
vamos a dejarlo en la bandeja de
salida por si acaso nos detienen denunciar
que estamos detenidos.
En el camino hacia allá fuimos
secuestrados por un grupo de
hombres vinculados a la policía,
política o seguridad del Estado.
Cuando nos interceptaron, yo tuve los segundos suficiente
para antes de que me entraran a la
fuerza en un carro, en un vehículo,
mandar por SMS, por mensaje de texto
aquél tuit que decía hemos sido detenidos.
Después dentro del auto
fue una escena de mucha violencia.
Había dos hombres que
uno estaba sobre mí, con su rodilla en mi pecho.
Me golpeaban, me alaban el cabello.
El conductor recibió una llamada,
miró hacia atrás y le dijo a los hombres
que me estaban golpeando,
"Déjenla, que ya lo saben."
Mi tuit había viajado
al mundo virtual, había viajado a internet,
y eso me estaba protegiendo todavía
en medio del acto represivo.
La información está ahora entrando por todos
los poros del sistema.
Y que trae la ruptura de la narrativa oficial,
el cuestionamiento, de cómo funciona el Ejecutivo,
las denuncias de corrupción, e las imágenes
de las injusticias.
Y todo eso, es un cóctel muy, muy agresivo
para el oficialismo.